quelle position défend Berlin concernant
l'envoi de ses chars léopards en Ukraine
difficile à dire tant la confusion et
palpable au sein même du gouvernement ce
dimanche soir la chef de la diplomatie
allemande c'est vu demander si
l'Allemagne serait prête à autoriser
l'apologne à envoyer ses chars en
Ukraine voici la réponse d'analena
berbock sur la chaîne LCI pour l'instant
la question n'a pas été posée mais si on
nous posait la question nous ne nous dit
opposerions pas
une déclaration qui a semé le trouble au
sein de la coalition au pouvoir et qui
est vu comme une pression sur le
chancelier de la part de la ministre
écologiste Olaf Scholtz qui lui reste
assez évasif lorsque la même question
lui est posée il préfère mettre en avant
la coopération européenne sur les aides
fournies à l'Ukraine
doit savoir qu'on ne va pas l'abandonner
nous allons continuer d'aider mais nous
avons un principe c'est un principe qui
je pense est très important nous
travaillons ensemble et nous nous
consultons
le ministre de la Défense a réagi très
rapidement à la déclaration de la chef
de la diplomatie
la décision dépend de beaucoup de
facteurs et prise de la Chancellerie
depuis plusieurs semaines l'Allemagne
est pressé par ses partenaires d'avoir
une position claire sur la question des
chars si elle se montre si hésitante
c'est parce qu'elle craint que l'envoi
de charlour a l'Ukraine soit considéré
comme le franchissement d'une ignorance
par Moscou